whoa Bessie whoa that's it oh you drove
me right in no better oh my but I
haven't even started the Lao my but I
haven't even no guards almost got gobble
up my butt Wow Wow is the wrong kind of
twerking drunk minecraft and happy
wheels this one's made by mini legend oh
hey hi there to the tiny box Tim just
died oh I get it
okay this is this the is supposed to be
the Minecraft what makes you think I'm
gonna be able to do it now thanks for
the well-wishes me get out of the
hospital but unfortunately this is gonna
put me right back in ok I don't have
friends to laugh at with my failures
what the [ __ ] was that all I have is to
laugh in myself because I'm so terrible
damn it
ok here we go but if I can't even get to
the little lady Biddy first why was that
a thing that happened ok huh oh [ __ ] no
I'm gonna miss I'm gonna miss markiplier
superstar I already knew that my mommy
told me I was a big superstar and then I
blew it up wait man
markable are deathtrap well just by the
name itself it sounds so fun
oh I'm dead I think I can actually beat
this thing on was a close one
I'm not gonna try again markiplier death
run well you could think that maybe
you'd name it a more pleasant NATO
markiplier death run what else would it
be Oh
today holy [ __ ] oh my god oh my god oh
my god so about my past level to 100
that only jammed it farther in no no kid
what happened to your what happened to
me what's happening to me oh good I
didn't need those added flexibility and
mobility whoa well you got me cuz I'm oh
hey how's it going there sexy lady
okey-dokey then
well good thing I'm done
ah my pelvis exploded ice at that time
of the day already
wonderful wait my balls well goodbye
where girl are invisible oh I'm sure
there's gonna go well am i dead already
seems like I might be dead oh wait i'm
sanna what am i doing door there's an
ice ball grab the mass pole and don't
hold space oh no quickly this is the
trout this is a drowning simulator game
by what the hell was that
that wasn't drowning oh okay oh I get it
okay alright I got it
Wow okay alright it's so weird it's so
weird for multiple reasons one because
it's totally silly but two because holy
crap it actually like is legit what the
hell I give up now oh hey how's it going
there is that me oh you're walking for
your welcome you're welcome for making
you smile I'm having to do way that's
cheating oh my lord ball throw haha
he lives at the shot he takes it yes
it's been so long since I play to kill
them all level and I do enjoy that
particular activity very much so to all
you bastard kitties you better get ready
sorry somehow I prematurely ended my
last kill them all for some damn reason
but here we go again my nightly killing
them all while I creepily talk about how
much I love killing them all which
admittedly is very weird but then again
I'm just stalling for time to make not a
murderer Marga blob all throw boy well
that's convenient ha
one more time Oh shattered levo blarf
yeah a full floor one Thank You universe
for making this level for me we okay
that wasn't too hard oh man my kid got
death made it didn't hurt I'm not hurt
at all you hurt little kitty back there
I always seem to be just fine oh boy oh
oh yeah I've never done one of those on
my first try before ray oh that actually
scared me
ah come on fast gotta go fast gotta go
fast gotta go slower
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video